le pape est accueilli comme une rockstar
par les Congolais une population pieuse
de 96 millions d'habitants 40% sont
catholiques des dizaines de milliers de
croyants ont bravé une chaleur
suffoquante pendant des heures pour voir
passer la pâte mobile dès son arrivée le
Saint-Père fait une déclaration
fracassante
de plusieurs cultures et peuples de
penser que l'Afrique doit être exploité
c'est terrible dit le Pape il demande au
pays riches de cesser de voir l'Afrique
comme une mine à exploiter une terre à
des valises
[Musique]
con au Canada depuis 30 ans 30 ans qu'il
essaie d'expliquer à ses amis et
collègues canadiens les horreurs qui se
déroulent dans l'est de son pays une
région extrêmement riche en minerais ou
des militaires et des dizaines de
millilitres certaines appuyées par
l'armée rwandaise se battent pour le
contrôle des mines
imaginez les enfants qui travaillent
dans des mines d'économiques qui
accessibles
il dit arrêtez de tout faire l'Afrique
arrêtez d'étouffer le Congo mais
l'exploitation des richesses qui ne
tiennent pas compte de l'humain de la
dignité humaine ça c'est
l'esclavagisation
m'excuse donc de l'être humain on ne
regarde plus l'être humain et on monte
sur et il n'y a rien qui se dit alors le
pape est arrivé je vous dis l'espoir
justement c'est qu'elle puisse dire une
parole qui dénonce cela il a dénoncé
près de 2 millions de Congolais ont
assisté à la première messe du pape
François tous partages cet espoir qu'il
va en faire réussir à tirer l'attention
du monde sur les conflits qui ravagent
la RDC depuis 25 ans
c'est violence on fait des millions de
morts dans l'indifférence sans compter
les dizaines de milliers de femmes et
d'enfants violées
comme cette jeune femme de 17 ans
qu'il voulait moi c'est le commandant
qui m'a désiré il m'a violé comme un
animal c'était une souffrance atroce le
papa du annuler sa visite à Goma la
ville au cœur de la région ravagée par
les combats mais il a insisté pour
rencontrer des victimes de ses conflits
des témoignages bouleversants mon grand
frère a été tué dans le circonstances
que nous ignorons jusqu'aujourd'hui mon
père lui a été tué à ma présence j'ai
suivi comment il a découper un morceau
puis sa tête trachée a été dans une
marmite
les couteaux
identiques à celui qui a tué tous les
membres de ma famille et
merci del pape pour votre courage et vos
témoignages face à la violence inhumaine
que vous avez vu de vos yeux et éprouvés
dans votre chair on reste sous le choc
il va conscientiser les gens j'espère
quoi même que les gens vont être touchés
et qui vont tranquillement commencer à
cheminer vers une paix qui permettrait
aux victimes de cette exploitation
humaine de soigner leur traumatisme
comme ce jeune homme qui a vu son père
se faire décapiter et qui a perdu sa
mère le même jour c'est
horrible d'assister à une paresse
elle ne me quitte jamais la nuit je ne
sais pas dormir c'est difficile de
comprendre une telle méchanceté
ici Sophie Langlois Radio-Canada
Montréal
[Musique]